tomorrow marks one year since george
floyd died at the hands of fired
minneapolis police officer derek shaubin
hundreds of people gathered in
minneapolis yesterday
calling for justice for victims of
police brutality in his speech to
congress last month president biden
challenged lawmakers to strike an
agreement on police reform
by tomorrow may 25th but congress is
nowhere close
to meeting that deadline nancy cordes is
the white house nancy good morning
good morning enrique well the president
is going to be hosting the floyd family
here at the white house on the
anniversary of george floyd's death
tomorrow and he had been hoping to
deliver the good news to them that
congress had reached a compromise
on police reform legislation instead he
will have to tell them that the two
sides are still talking over the weekend
one of the key negotiators new jersey
senator cory booker
said that they are making what he called
meaningful progress on a bill that would
among other things
ban police choke holds provide more
funding for police body cameras
and create a national database for
police use of force
and at this point police reform
advocates don't appear to be
too alarmed by the fact that this is
dragging on the reverend al sharpton
said
that he'd rather have a bill with teeth
that's late
than a toothless bill that is done on
time
now the biggest sticking point continues
to be what's known as
qualified immunity which often protects
officers from being sued
in civil court for wrongdoing many
democrats want to roll back those
protections
many republicans do not and the white
house at this point
is really playing a supporting role in
these talks it is not nearly as involved
in the negotiations
as it is in say infrastructure talks and
right now gail that appears to be an
arrangement that democrats and
republicans
are most comfortable with nancy thank
you you make a good point i've never
heard of anything toothless that's a
good thing
thank you very much